2020
brought us uh a couple of in the physics
world uh theories of everything
uh eric weinstein kind of i mean he's
been working for
probably decades but he put out this
idea of
geometric unity or started sort of
publicly thinking and talking about it
more
stephen wolfram put out his physics
project which is kind of this hypograph
view of the theory of everything
do you uh find uh interesting beautiful
things
to these theories of everything what do
you think about the physics world and
sort of
uh the beautiful interesting insightful
mathematics
in in that world whether we're talking
about quantum mechanics which you
touched on in a bunch of your videos a
little bit
quaternions like just the mathematics
involved or general relativity
which is more about surfaces and
topology all that stuff
well i think um as far as like
popularized science is concerned
people are more interested in theories
of everything than they should be
like because the problem is whether
we're talking about
trying to make sense of weinstein's
lectures or wolfram's project or let's
just say like
listening to uh whit written talk about
string theory
whatever proposed path to a theory of
everything
um you're not actually going to
understand it some physicists will but
like
you're just not actually going to
understand the substance of what they're
saying what i think is way way more
productive
is to let yourself get really interested
in the phenomena that are still
deep but which you have a chance of
understanding because the path to
getting
to like even understanding what
questions these theories of everything
are trying to answer
involves like walking down that um i
mean i was watching a video before i
came here about
from steve mold talking about um why
sugar polarizes light in a certain way
so fascinating like really really
interesting it's not
like this novel theory of everything
type thing but to
understand what's going on there really
requires digging in in depth to
certain ideas and if you let yourself
think past what the video tells you
about
what does circularly polarized light
mean and things like that it actually
would get you to a pretty good
appreciation of like two state states
and quantum systems
um in a way that just trying to read
about like
oh what's the um what are the hard parts
about resolving quantum field theories
with general relativity
is never going to get you so as far as
popularizing science is concerned
like the audience should be less
interested than they are
in theories of everything um the
popularizers should be
less emphatic than they are about that
for like actual practicing physicist
you know it might be the case maybe more
people should think about fundamental
questions
but it's difficult to create uh like a
three blue one brown video on
the theory of everything so basically
we should really try to find the beauty
and mathematics of physics by
looking at concepts that are like within
reach yeah i think that's super
important i mean so
you see this in math too with um the big
unsolved problems
so like the clay millennium problems
riemann hypothesis um
have you ever done a video on farmers
last name no i have not yet no
but if i did do you know what i would do
i would talk about um
proving fairmont's last theorem in the
specific case of n equals three
okay is that still accessible though yes
actually
barely um mathologer might be able to do
like a great job on this he does a good
job of taking stuff that's barely
accessible and making it
but the the core ideas of proving it for
n equals three are hard
but they do get you real ideas about
algebraic number theory
it involves looking at a number field
that's uh it lives in the complex plane
it looks like a hexagonal lattice
and you start asking questions about
factoring numbers in this hexagonal
lattice
so it takes a while but i've talked
about this sort of like lattice
arithmetic
in other contexts and you can get to a
okay understanding of that and the
things that make fairmont's last theorem
hard are actually quite deep
um and so the cases that we can solve it
for it's like you can get these broad
sweeps
based on some hard but like accessible
um bits of number theory but before you
can even understand why the general case
is as hard as it is you have to walk
through those
and so any other attempt to describe it
would just end up being like
shallow and not really productive for
the viewers time um
i think the same goes for most like
unsolved problem type things where
i think you know as a kid i was actually
very inspired by the
twin prime conjecture um that like
totally sucked me in it's this
thing that was understandable i kind of
had this dream like oh maybe i'll be the
one to prove the twin prime conjecture
and new math that i would learn would be
like viewed through this lens of
like oh maybe i can apply it to that in
some way but uh
you sort of mature to a point where you
realize that uh
you should spend your brain cycles on
problems that you will see resolved
because then you're going to
grow to see what it feels like for these
things to be resolved rather than
spending your brain cycles on something
where it's not it's not going to pan out
and the people who do make progress
towards these things like james maynard
uh is a great example here of like young
creative mathematician who
like pushes in the direction of things
like the twin prime conjecture
rather than hitting that head on just
see all the interesting questions that
are hard for similar reasons but become
more
tractable and let themselves really
engage with those
so i think people should get in that
habit i think the popularization of
physics should encourage that habit
through things like the physics of
simple everyday phenomena
because it can get quite deep and um
yeah i think you know i've heard a lot
of the interest that you know people
send me messages asking to explain
weinstein's thing or asking to explain
wolfram's thing
one i don't understand them but more
importantly um
you shouldn't be interested in those
right it's a giant
sort of uh ball of interesting ideas
there's probably a million of
interesting ideas in there
that individually could be explored
effectively and to be clear
you should be interested in fundamental
questions i think that's a good habit to
ask what the fundamentals of things are
but i think it takes a lot of steps
to like certainly you shouldn't be
trying to answer that unless you
actually understand quantum field theory
and you actually
understand general relativity that's the
cool thing about like your videos people
who haven't done mathematics
like if you really give it time watch it
a couple of times and like
try to try to reason about it you can
actually understand the concept that's
being explained
and it's not a coincidence that the
things i'm describing aren't
like the most um up-to-date uh progress
on the riemann hypothesis
cousins or um like there's context in
which the analog of the remain
hypothesis has been solved in like more
uh discrete feeling finite settings that
are more well behaved
i'm not describing that because it just
takes a ton to get there
and instead i think it'll be like
productive to have an actual
understanding of something
that can you can pack into 20 minutes i
think that's beautifully put
ultimately that's where like the most
satisfying thing is when you really
understand
um yeah really understand build a habit
of feeling what it's like to actually
come to resolution yeah yeah
as opposed to which it can also be
enjoyable but just being
in awe of the fact that you don't
understand anything yeah that's not like
i don't know maybe people get
entertainment out of that but
it's not as fulfilling as understanding
you won't grow
yeah and but also just the fulfilling it
really does feel good when you
first don't understand something and
then you do that's a beautiful feeling
you